Dottie said you're an idiot first word  is already wrong as you know almost a  requirement in these emails that you use  the wrong you're you're an idiot you  don't talk about our president that way  president Trump is our president and he  said exactly what he should have said  those people that are in jail are not  criminals they're innocent people that  were put there just to show face in the  Democratic party so don't talk about  President Trump he's exactly right and  he's not confused about anything you're  the one that's confused examine your own  mind open up your mind and realize what  you're saying he's a smart ass and the  best president we've ever had  one sentence  I guess no punctuation  complete cult  commitment  to Donald Trump and mega trumpism